So I think it will help if we think
through what the basic update rule is
when you're doing reinforcement
learning,or cue learning.
And then to try to adapt to this
notion that are we're representing our
value function using some kind
of function approximater.
>> All right.
>> So here's a way to think about this,
we've got Q function that we're
going to try to represent as
some function of a set of parameters,
or weights.
Maybe let's say one set of
parameters for each action.
>> Sure.
>> And
what F is doing is taking a state and
translating it into a set of features.
We're going to feed those features and
the parameters of the function
into something called F.
And what will come out of
that will be the Q value.
So this is intended
to be fairly general.
And we'll talk about some specific
examples of this in a moment.
But let's just imagine that when Q
is being represented by some kind of
function approximater, and
here's how Q learning works.
We have an experienced couple that
comes in, state, action, reward next,
state and then we do an update.
Now what's the update usually?
We try to move the the value of
that state action pair a little bit
towards the reward plus the discounted
value of the next state S prime.
So, that's the bellman equation
kind of hidden in here and
the difference between that and
the current Q value is the TD error.
And what do we want to
do with the TD error?
The TD error tells us is our
current prediction too high,
too low, just right.
You know does it like porridge?
And what we want to do is change.
[LAUGH]
>> That's the three bears I guess.
But the fact that matter is we actually
need to know the kind of the direction
that we should be going.
Are we too high or too low and we want
to move the parameters that represent
the Q function, you know so
a given weight say W super a sub i.
We want to move it a little bit,
this is a learning rate alpha,
in the direction of that TD Error.
But how much do we move the weight,
depends on how that weight actually
influences the Q function, right?
So what's the partial derivative of
the Q value for that state action pair
as a function of that particular
weight that we want to change?
And we're going to change that weight
proportion, we're going to change things
proportionately to that,
to that gradient.
So this should look kind of familiar.
Does this look familiar?
>> Yeah, it looks exactly like the,
you know, we drew up the update rule.
The things that we did with perceptrons.
Yeah, it's a normal kind
of gradient update rule.
>> Yeah, right.
Exactly so.
Right and so
when you're representing a function in
terms of a set of parameters we want to
know how did the parameters impact the
value that we're predicting and let's
move those parameters in a direction
that makes the prediction more accurate.
So, this is a way that we can actually
view Q learning as an update rule for
underlying parameters of a function or
proxy.
And I guess the only difference is that,
unlike the sort of y star minus
y thing that we used to do, this is
what we got on this particular step.
So that's what makes a TD Error
as opposed to actual error,
if that makes any sense.
Does that make sense?
>> Yeah, I think that's exactly right.
So when we were thinking about
supervised learning, what was happening
is we have some kind of output for
our current input and we'll call that y.
And then we have a target output, y*.
And we want to change
the parameters of the function so
that instead of getting something like
y we get something much more like y*.
So I think think what your point is is
that this Bellman equation kind of value
and this kind of current prediction
do play the rules of y* and y.
So this I think is
a really good analogy.
But one way that it's different is that
why star when we're doing supervised
learning is actually the right value,
right?
It's coming from some kind of
trusted source, and it is the label.
Here, we're bootstrapping,
which I think is a kind of wrapping.
And what we're doing with bootstrapping
is we're using our current predictions
as a kind of way of making a target for
what our other prediction
should be moving toward.
So, this this should look
a little bit unnerving.
But, it's not a bad idea but
it's also not clearly of great idea
because instead of using real label data
we're actually making up our own labels
using the current prediction
from the Q function.
>> Right.
>> And we'll see
sometimes this can really
run us in a trouble and
we have to be a little bit careful
to make sure that it doesn't.
Okay.
>> Right?
So this is in a very general form.
I think it would be helpful though to
make it make more sense if we dive in
and think about some particular
representations of the Q function.
>> Okay.